Whether they feature lo-fi
samurai or jazzy bounty hunters,
these are the best anime openings that
you won't be skipping any time soon.
The best openings don't always come from
the best anime. Is "Lucky Star" a series
that stands the test of time? Not really. The
humor is a mix of dry slice-of-life material
that other shows have done better, with plenty
of otaku culture references that instantly date
the series to 2007. Older fans seeking a
nostalgic flashback to a previous era of
anime might find some enjoyment in revisiting the
series, but the majority of the fun is contained
in the opening theme "Motteke! Sailor Fuku,"
which translates to "Take It! Sailor Clothes."
The majority of "Lucky Star" is very
slow-paced, but the opening sequence
is pure hyperactive energy. The lyrics,
consisting mostly of nonsense about school
uniforms performed by voice actors Aya
Hirano, Emiri Katou, Kaori Fukuhara, and
Aya Endo. The dancing takes after the ending
theme to Kyoto Animation's previous hit "The
Melancholy of Haruhi Suzumiya," and makes
for a super entertaining bit of animation.
"Just Between Us" by Chatmonchy is a cute and
fitting theme song for "Princess Jellyfish,"
a dramedy about a jellyfish-obsessed woman who
befriends a beautiful crossdresser and has to keep
her man-fearing roommates from finding out. What
really makes this opening sequence special and
worthy of inclusion on this list isn't so much the
song itself, but the visuals that accompany it.
In just 90 seconds, this opening fits in
references to "Sex and the City," "Star
Wars," "Singin' in the Rain," "Mary
Poppins," "The Graduate," James Bond,
and even Bruce Lee. The first time you see it,
it's the perfect bizarre hook for the show,
and once you start watching, you
come to appreciate how well the
smaller details in all these parodies
fit each character's personalities.
"Pop Team Epic" is one of the
strangest anime comedies around,
a collection of short mixed-media skits
that feature multiple voice actors taking
the roles of the chaotic schoolgirls
Popuko and Pipimi. The opening theme,
a techno track also titled "Pop Team Epic"
performed by Sumire Uesaka, is a bomb of
pure sensory overload that manages to perfectly
encapsulate the chaos that the show is known for.
Starting with a nail-covered baseball bat
destroying a TV set, the images that make
up this high-octane intro are as hilarious as
they are fleeting. These girls are everywhere,
showing up in random places across the
globe, spying on you in different forms,
and traveling through time to remake the
world. Why do they exist? What do they
want with us? No one knows for sure…
but we should probably be very afraid.
"Your life has been spared!"
Before lofi hip hop became inextricably linked
to anime girls studying, there was "Samurai
Champloo." This 2004 anime about two rival
ronin working together to help a girl find
"the samurai who smells of sunflowers"
brought hip hop music and attitude into
Edo period Japan. Director Shinichiro Watanabe
is perhaps the best anime director around when
it comes to effectively using music, and his
anime always have outstanding opening themes.
The "Samurai Champloo" theme song "Battlecry"
was composed by the late, great Nujabes,
with lyrics written and performed by Shing02.
The mix of contemporary musical styles with
traditional Japanese art, and of chill beats
with intense lyrics and violent action,
provide a striking first impression for
anyone not yet familiar with the show.
A number of anime have made effective use
of Western pop and rock songs for openings
over the years, including Duran Duran's
"Girls on Film" in "Speed Grapher," The
Delgados' "The Light Before We Land" in
"Gunslinger Girl," and Oasis' "Falling
Down" in "Eden of the East." One of the
most famous examples of this, though,
is the use of "Duvet" by Bôa in the 1998
cyberpunk classic "Serial Experiments Lain."
"Serial Experiments Lain," a show
about a teenage girl drawn into a
web of online conspiracies, is at once
artsy, complex, scary, depressing,
and yet also beautiful — all features that
the opening theme exemplifies. The credits
open with an ominous narrator letting you know
exactly when this particular series takes place.
"Present day… present time! Hahahahaha—"
The bizarre message is followed up by the
smooth sounds of "Duvet" and a showcase of the
anime's striking visuals. "Lain" was certainly
prophetic about the dangers of the Metaverse,
but the internet today doesn't look
anywhere near as cool as it did here.
A list of the best anime opening themes
wouldn't be complete without at least
one upbeat shonen opening. Long-running battle
shonen tend to cycle through a lot of openings,
so options for this category
were numerous. After all,
ranking the best "Naruto" or "One Piece"
themes could be full lists unto themselves.
"Yu Yu Hakusho" has a somewhat unusual
advantage, in that it used the super
catchy song "Hohoemi no Bakudan" — or "Smile
Bomb" — for the entirety of its 112-episode
run from 1992 to 1995. Changes were made to the
opening animation in Episode 67 and Episode 94,
but the iconic tune has always remained the same.
"Smile Bomb" was performed in
Japanese by Matsuko Mawatari. However,
"Yu Yu Hakusho" was among the first anime
dubbed by Funimation, which used to create
English language translations of the opening
music to accompany their dubs. Thankfully,
the English version of "Smile Bomb" by Sara White
manages to be just as good as the Japanese one.
Some anime purists might consider it sacrilege
to list an American opening theme on this
list — much less one from 4Kids Entertainment,
the infamous former dubbing studio that gave us
the horrific "One Piece" rap among other crimes
against music. But every rule has an exception,
and the English opening to the first season of
"Pokemon," performed by Jason Paige, may be the
single localized opening theme that is actually
an improvement over the original Japanese one.
If you were young — or young at heart — when
"Pokemon" hit the airwaves in the late-90s,
you can no doubt recite the lyrics to the opening
theme song by heart. Start singing "I wanna be the
very best" at an anime convention, and you can
guarantee that others will join in with "like
no one ever was." If you need more evidence of
this infectiously catchy song's superiority,
keep in mind that when "Pokemon" was exported
globally, other countries didn't adapt the
Japanese theme or make their own openings — they
dubbed the English theme. It's just that powerful
around the world, with the ability to keep us
motivated in even the most difficult times.
"It's you and me… I know
it's my destiny, Pokemon!"
Every season of "Mob Psycho 100" thus far has had
incredible opening themes, each performed by the
series' own musical group, Mob Choir. The first
opening, titled "99," arguably deserves to be on
this list for its beautiful animation, inspiring
lyrics, and the intense countdown ratcheting up
the anxiety. "1," the third season's opening, was
released months in advance of the season premiere,
and proved to be another masterpiece even
without the context of the new episodes.
If we had to choose, however, "99.9" — the
second season's opening featuring the band
Sajou no Hana alongside the Mob Choir —
is the best possible choice to represent
"Mob Psycho 100." "99" was always
going to be a hard opening to top,
but "99.9" went above and beyond with
even more exciting music and trippy
animation. It won best opening sequence
at the 2020 Crunchyroll Anime Awards,
and some critics and fans have gone so far as to
declare it the best anime opening of all time.
Gentleman thief Lupin the 3rd could probably
be considered the anime world's equivalent of
James Bond. As such, it's only fitting that
his theme music is as cool and instantly
memorable as 007's — even if he didn't receive
it in his first appearance. Directed by future
Studio Ghibli co-founders Hayao Miyazaki
and Isao Takahata, "Lupin the 3rd Part I"
was something of a mixed bag. The first half
of the series is dark and gritty in places,
while the second half is more family-friendly.
The creators were still figuring out what
worked for the character, and its repetitive
theme is definitely not one of the greats.
"Opera fan, probably." "Everybody's a critic."
"Lupin the 3rd Part III" went in
a different, wackier direction,
and its opening reflects that. However, it was
the theme for "Lupin the 3rd Part II" that became
the true "Lupin" theme. Remixed multiple
times over the course of the series' run,
it set the standard for jazzy adventure anime
themes and has influenced countless anime
openings. In the 21st century, "Part
IV," "Part V," and "Part VI" have all
returned to the "Part II" theme while adding
their own great animated sequences on top.
Satoshi Kon didn't make anime the way anyone
else did, and the opening sequence to "Paranoia
Agent" — the one TV series he directed before
his death in 2010 — is unlike any other. "Yume no
Shima Shinen Kouen" — or "Dream Island Obsessional
Park" — by composer Susumu Hirasawa was designed
to instantly wake up viewers tuning into this
2004 late-night psychological horror series.
"Paranoia Agent" is all about the allures and
dangers of escaping from the difficulties of
reality, and the opening sequence illustrates this
theme in the eeriest way possible. The show's cast
of characters are shown drowning underwater,
falling from the sky, and standing in the middle
of traffic, all while laughing hysterically.
The bombastic electronic music is overpowering
in a way that feels like yet another level of
disassociation, with lyrics about beautiful
mushroom clouds and not worrying about tsunamis
contributing to the surreal sense of disaster.
Can a great opening alone turn an anime into
a phenomenon? The TV adaptation of Hajime
Isayama's "Attack on Titan" was going
to be a blockbuster hit no matter what,
but the effectiveness of its first
opening certainly helped its success.
Linked Horizon's "Feuerroter Pfeil und
Bogen" — from the German for "Crimson Bow
and Arrow" — sold skeptics on this particular
show potentially being the coolest thing ever.
The plot of "Attack on Titan" turned messy and
controversial, but even if you hate the show
itself, this opening is still perfectly calibrated
to get your blood pumping and make you want
to fight some Titans yourself. The show has had
similarly great openings in its later seasons, but
none can match the first one — every action-packed
second of this theme became instantly iconic.
The figure skating romance "Yuri on Ice"
became an instant phenomenon among anime
fans in 2016. It ended up sweeping the
first ever Crunchyroll Anime Awards,
winning all seven categories it was nominated
in. While there was some controversy about the
show winning so many awards against some
worthy competitors, it's still undoubtedly
one of the best anime of the past decade.
Regardless, "History Maker" by Dean Fujioka
was a genuinely deserving winner for best opening
and deserves the number four spot on this list.
"Well, this won't be an official record, but
that score's among the top ten in the world!"
Performed in English, the lyrics to "History
Maker" are all sung by Fujioka, but are written
essentially as a duet. The first verse is from the
perspective of the anxiety-ridden Yuri, while the
second is from the point of view of his supportive
coach Victor. The triumphant chorus is meant to be
the two of them together. The beautiful music is
matched with equally beautiful animation, with
stylized and expressive renderings of the main
characters skating their way around the screen.
As the "Lucky Star" girls proved, having
anime characters dance to their own theme
songs can be an easy formula for a winning
introduction. "Keep Your Hands Off Eizouken!"
provides another dance-heavy opening,
set to the upbeat anthem "Easy Breezy"
by the rap duo Chelmico. It stands out
both due to the sheer catchiness of the
music and the personality the artists
at Science SARU put into the animation.
"Keep Your Hands Off Eizouken!" is about
high school girls making their own anime.
Unlike most other high school anime, where
characters tend to be at least drawn if not
written as idealized archetypes, the "Eizouken"
girls are designed to be as quirky as their
personalities. This definitely comes across
in the opening: Asakusa's awkward charm,
Kanamori's cynical confidence, and Mizusaki's
freewheeling joy can be seen directly in their
moves. The second half of the opening moves
on from the dancing to a fast-paced barrage
of iconography associated with the characters,
building to an incredibly exciting title drop.
If this list were specifically ranking
the most influential anime openings,
then "A Cruel Angel's Thesis" from "Neon
Genesis Evangelion" would probably clinch
the top spot. Performed by Yoko Takahashi,
the song is sung from the perspective of a
maternal figure inspiring a young boy to
"become a legend." An uplifting contrast
to a show that would soon prove itself to be
extremely dark and heavy, "A Cruel Angel's
Thesis" exploded in popularity even beyond the
massive success of "Evangelion" itself — it
was the single most popular karaoke song of
Japan's Heisei era, according to Crunchyroll.
The opening sequence's visuals have proven
just as iconic as the music. "Evangelion"
might have gone through some significant
changes over the course of its production,
but the opening's rapid montage of images, title
cards, and symbolism is packed with foreshadowing
that pays off at the end of the series. It's
probably the ideal of what people think of as
an "anime opening," and it's been lovingly
parodied on numerous occasions as a result.
Three, two, one, let's jam. Yoko Kanno is perhaps
the greatest composer to have ever worked in
anime — her themes for "Vision of Escaflowne"
and "Wolf's Rain" were both under consideration
for this list. What was never in question,
however, was that "Tank!," the iconic opening
to Shinichiro Watanabe's beloved sci-fi Western
"Cowboy Bebop," was certain to be number one.
Though "Tank!" and "Cowboy Bebop" as a whole took
clear inspiration from "Lupin III," they have
always stood out from the general popular trends
in anime. The incredible big band jazz tune makes
for one of the coolest sequences in anime history
— even if Jet isn't the biggest fan of the genre.
"I thought you like jazz.”
"Don't be dense. I started
wailing the blues when the
doctor whacked my bottom on the day I was born."
This highly influential opening
theme was many years in the making,
as Kanno explained during an interview with
Red Bull Music Academy. She elaborated —
"The seeds for that score were sown in middle
school and high school when I was a member of
the brass band [...] I wanted to play brass
music that shook your soul, made your blood boil,
and made you lose it. [...] I wanted to make music
which would light a fire in me when I played it."
That fire caught hold of countless
anime fans across the world,
and it still burns brightly to this day.